[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es einen
klassischen saftigen nuss schoko
gugelhupf das ist einfach so klasse
schlecker dem markt man immer und ich
verfeinere ihm später noch mit meiner
schokocreme das natürlich euch
überlassen wird euch aber alle genauen
mengenangaben unten in die infobox
schreiben und auch sein alternativen
chocobos falls sie jetzt gerade zufällig
nicht da hab i startet direkt mit einer
kurzen vorbereitung dafür nehme ich mir
die zeit bitter kuvertüre taxi einmal
fein und wird sie dann bei ca 600 watt
in der mikrowelle schmelzen und dann
abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
für die kuvertüre ist geschmolzen die
haselnuss habe ich kurz angeröstet in
der pfanne und lasse ich auch noch mal
abkönnen das macht einfach viel leckeres
aroma und jetzt habe ich noch ein trick
denn ich habe heute auch vergessen meine
mutter rechtzeitig aus dem kühlschrank
zu holen die habe ich jetzt schon in
stücke geschnitten und wird jetzt ein
trick anwenden damit sie schneller auf
zimmertemperatur kommt weil wenn sie
kalt ist dann lässt sie sich nicht so
gut hören dafür habe ich jetzt hier
einfach nur große schüssel gibt da heißt
es wasser rein trocknen sie aus und gibt
sie dann kopfüber wieder drauf
[Musik]
und jetzt je nachdem wie kalt es fünf
bis zehn minuten warten und dadurch wird
sie halt weich und wir können direkt
gleich die küchenmaschine nehmen und ihr
dürft übrigens natürlich auch hier in
dem rezeptor handrührgerät benutzen
falls sie keinen küchenmaschine habt so
ich starte jetzt mit dem talk alles
wirklich ein sehr schnelles rezept ich
gebe jetzt die weich gewordene butter
einmal in die küchenmaschine da kommt
zucker mit dazu und dann wird das drei
minuten nach vor geschwindigkeit gerührt
und danach gebe ich die zimmer waren
eier mit dazu und rühren jedes einzelnen
so circa 20 sekunden ein
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich auch schon die tat
bitter kuvertüre rhein gegeben da auch
darauf achten dass sie wirklich nur noch
handwarm ist und allgemein darauf achten
dass die zutaten zimmertemperatur haben
denn eier und butter die verbinden sich
nicht ganz so gut aber so habt ihr halt
keine großen stückchen oder probleme
dass die halb zwei komplett
unterschiedliche temperaturen haben und
als nächstes völlig alle trockenen
zutaten nicht mehr mail gemeine
haselnüsse bakker kann es einfach noch
ein bisschen intensiver wird backpulver
und gehackte haselnüsse die förderlich
erst mal in einer großen schüssel und
geht sie dann mit zur mit zum teil
[Musik]
der teig ist auch schon fertig ging echt
schnell so sieht er aus von der
konsistenz und ich werde ihnen jetzt
auch direkt einfüllen ich nehme mir
gesagt heute einen guglhupf form und
werde sie jetzt erstmal mit butter
ausstreichen
und dann bemühen ich nehme aber mail mit
back
damit dann später am äußeren rand meines
google books ist nicht alles so wie es
aussieht
[Musik]
jetzt würde ich den teig ein und
streiche an der oberfläche alles schön
glatt und dann kommt in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 170 grad ober und
unterhitze für 48 bis 50 minuten macht
auf jeden fall gern die stäbchen probe
und das geniale an diesem kuchen ist
dass er sich wirklich fünf tage lang
hält und die bleibt immer saftig der ist
einfach genial
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich den google ruft noch mal
vollständig auskühlen lassen denn dann
bekommt ihn ganz einfach aus der form
einfach stürzen nimmt dafür zum beispiel
so ein up kühl gitter oder auch teller
das auch kein problem
umdrehen
ich gebe mein google hofft jetzt auf
eine schöne tortenplatte wundert euch
nicht dass der sehr dunkel aussieht das
liegt am bug cacau job in der kamera
wirkt auch noch mal ein ton dunkler da
dürft euch nicht daran stören oder falls
sie nicht nackig lasst dann könnt ihr
natürlich auch euro vor mit paniermehl
ausstreuen wenn wir es nicht so dunkel
ich mach jetzt noch den besten kuss der
welt oben drüber und zwar nehme ich
meine schokocreme das ist ja auch eine
haselnuss krämer aus der perfekt zum
kuchen einfach bei 600 watt für 45
sekunden in die mikrowelle geben
alternativ einfach im wasserbad und
bisschen erwärmen dann wird ziemlich
richtig schön flüssig und jetzt den
kompletten kuchen damit noch
einstreichen ich bin da eventuell
gleichen pinsel aber ich gucke einfach
mal wie es optisch am schönsten aussieht
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der berühmte test test ich
habe übrigens zur deko nur noch
haselnuss krokant und
das kam so verwirrt mich als in dir
kommen wir probieren richtig heftig
lecker aus also alle die haare fallen
ihr haben schaut weg
wir probieren von einem stück
europa teil ist romantik ist so hallo
wach weil dadurch der knallt 1000 colada
ist richtig schokolade und das ist
lustig lustig schokoladig tun hast du
diese hasen bis zu lieben so nusskuchen
mit lokal mega also richtig geile kombi
war es könnte auch so ein riegel sein
dass ein frieden mega wohl stärker dazu
so einen leckeren latte setzte diese
proteine regeln ist ein bisschen ein
bisschen frau constanze ich weiß aber
dass sie wollen gerne gesungen aber sie
schaffen ja stimmt ja genau und lecker
schokocreme euro ja es hat doch sehr oft
sind videos dass das eine kurve süßen
aber diese wirklich ist die sind diese
papiere aber gerade richtig süß leute
macht die nach komm zurück zum video und
schreibt mal feedback unten in den
kommentaren und ansonsten nicht ich kann
mir den genießer ich gönne mir den es
neben kaffee und haben so haut sein
stück ziehen noch weg und dann
vernichten wir euch die spaß und
nachmachen
manchmal kann es
einbricht so einfach so in die mitte und
hessen
[Musik]